Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Riccardo Sasso
Sono nata in ritardo, per questo corro:
ma non sono la persona migliore
per parlarvi di maratone.
Nasco il 5 febbraio 1973.
Allora, tecnicamente, la data corretta
sarebbe stato il tre,
giorno in cui si sono rotte
le acque di mia mamma;
ma lei, facendo un patto col diavolo
e uno con la natura
ha continuato le consegne
del sabato pomeriggio,
le pulizie della domenica,
e mi è toccato nascere il 5.
Come prima della mia nascita,
anche dopo la mia nascita
in casa si è continuato a correre.
Allora, mio papà correva davvero:
perché guidava gli autobus,
poi correva a dare una mano
a mamma in bottega,
poi correva in Comune
a fare attività politica.
La nonna, poverina,
correva tutto il giorno
dietro me e mio fratello;
e poi anche lei dava una mano
in bottega alla mamma;
insomma, una fatica incredibile.
E poi, sono gli anni '70;
e mia nonna, che di guerre
ne aveva vissute due,
aveva il terrore che mancasse
il cibo in tavola,
per cui la pentola bolliva bolliva,
bolliva, bolliva 24 ore al giorno.
E la parola più ricorrente,
quando mettevamo le gambe sotto il tavolo
era: "Presto, mangia, che diventi grande"
Un incubo!
Quindi capite che non sono di sicuro
cresciuta in una famiglia oziosa.
A otto anni, per osmosi e per gioco,
lavo le scale dell'intero palazzo
dove viviamo, ascensore incluso.
Sono stata una studentessa fuori corso,
con tanti lavoretti:
barista, commessa, cameriera.
Durante un'estate,
quella dei miei 16 anni,
ho venduto corsi di inglese porta a porta:
il paese era grosso così,
mi conoscevano tutti:
Corsi d'inglese venduti,
devo dire, neanche uno;
ma ho fatto una quantità
di merende incredibili.
Poi, l'ultimo lavoro
prima di quello definitivo
è stato "gestione e recupero crediti"
per un'importante società bancaria;
eh, ovviamente i crediti
erano irrecuperabili,
come voi potete immaginare.
Con le provvigioni che ho preso
dal lavoro che facevo
non ci ho neanche pagato
l'abbonamento del treno;
però mio papà, stoico, diceva:
"ricordati che quando io ero piccolo,
per andare a bottega a imparare qualcosa
i genitori miei dovevano ancora
dare qualcosa al maestro.
Per cui, impara l'arte
e mettila da parte, ragazza,
che fai prima.
A 27 anni cerco di laurearmi,
e arriva il lavoro che non sogno
ma che mi ha fatta innamorare follemente,
ed è stato un bellissimo lavoro.
Un'azienda che sbarca in Italia
con un concetto commerciale
completamente nuovo.
Sono stati anni di vorticosa crescita,
di energia.
Eravamo galvanizzati.
E anche io sono cresciuta velocemente:
quattro promozioni in sei anni.
E poi, finalmente arriva
la mia bambina, arriva Anastasia.
Tre mesi a casa,
poi qualcosa nello stomaco
comincia a girare,
sentivo il bisogno di tornare
nel mio habitat naturale - l'ufficio!
Quindi, con la scusa di dare
il cambio ai colleghi
durante le vacanze di Natale,
eccomi guerriera con mamma, bambina,
carrozzina al seguito
il 27 di dicembre.
È stato un rientro bello frizzante,
perché di lì a poco, neanche un mese,
è arrivata una nuova promozione,
un nuovo incarico.
E allora, lì mi sono trovata
in cima alla piramide organizzativa.
Che fare?
Eh, avevo lavorato
su quello stesso progetto
per i sette anni precedenti -  e quindi?
Quel giro nello stomaco
si era trasformato in un pugno.
Cosa c'era che non andava?
C'era che adesso la barca la guidavo io.
Mi sono sentita completamente
inadeguata, incompetente,
ho avuto tantissima paura.
Ho sentito il giudizio,
il fiato del giudizio
degli altri sul mio collo;
e l'ho temuto tantissimo.
Per sopravvivere, quindi, ho adottato
un approccio efficacissimo.
Velocità, sopravvivenza;
sopravvivenza, velocità,
dritti alla meta con salto agli ostacoli.
Le cose che non ero capace di fare?
Le facevo ugualmente,
senza lasciarle fare agli altri,
che sapevano peraltro farle
molto meglio di me!
Perché il mio obiettivo
erano i risultati aziendali,
l'essere riconosciuta come una persona
valida e degna di quel posto.
E poi c'era il mio territorio,
io volevo portare bene alla mia gente,
volevo far crescere
l'economia di quel posto.
Per cui, mi sono ritrovata
in una situazione veramente complicata.
A casa, come in ufficio,
tutti presi dal ticchettio dell'orologio,
non non si dava tempo
neanche di raccogliere le persone,
o aiutare le persone
che erano inciampate in ostacoli
che non erano riuscite a superare.
"Poi torno", dicevo, "Poi torno".
E a volte, invece, poi non tornavo.
E con gli obiettivi di famiglia,
anche li, a tutto gas!
Machiavelli disse, una volta,
"Il fine giustifica i mezzi";
e se avessimo giocato una partita
sarebbe finita così:
Daniela - Machiavelli, uno a zero.
Un giorno stavo allattando
la mia piccola bambina
e il telefono, mentre stavo
mandando una mail,
le cade direttamente  sulla testa.
Dopo un attimo di preoccupazione,
mi sarei dovuta fermare:
quello poteva essere un segnale,
e dopo 15 anni lo riconosco.
Allora, ho solo pensato:
"Speriamo che la mail non sia partita,
che era ancora in bozza".
Sono passati sei anni,
anni di grandi soddisfazioni, di corse,
di grandi gioie professionali;
ma anche di irte salite
e di qualche dolore,
perché altri bambini non ne arrivavano.
E poi è arrivato Michelangelo.
L'estate in cui è nato Michelangelo,
che ho passato in maternità,
è stata una bella estate,
calma, tranquilla,
con i bambini che giocavano
e dormivano sotto un albero o al mare.
Vivevamo in una casa ristrutturata
proprio di fresco in quel momento,
ovviamente facendo dannare
muratori, amici e architetto
quasi fino a perdere tutto quanto.
E poi, ad agosto, di nuovo
quel bollore allo stomaco.
E torno in ufficio,
per dare di nuovo il cambio
ai colleghi che andavano in vacanza.
E cosa ho trovato?
Una sorpresa meravigliosa:
un team cresciuto, splendidamente evoluto,
rafforzato dall'unicità
delle persone che lo componevano.
E non mi dimenticherò mai
il giorno in cui mi dissero:
"Dani, mentre eri via abbiamo fatto così:
cosa ne dici, funziona?"
"Funziona!" avrei voluto dire io:
e invece sono rimasta così stordita
che non mi sono, neanche quella volta,
fermata a festeggiare e a celebrare
concedendomi il diritto alla parola "Stop"
e il loro a prendersi i propri spazi.
Però, qualcosa stava già cambiando,
c'era di nuovo qualche cosa
che si muoveva in me;
e più e più volte,
erano più le volte che la mia anima
agitava il cartellino rosso.
Se da un lato i risultati sul lavoro,
i risultati economici,
avevano una barra dritta così,
quelli sul clima aziendale
andavano giù così;
e in casa, la cosa che più
frequentemente mi sentivo dire
era "quel caratteraccio,
Dani, mettilo a bada
che non sei mica in ufficio!"
Mi ci sono voluti molti anni
per elaborare e per fare un percorso
che però allora sentivo proprio
di non poter più rimandare.
Ma perché corriamo?
Corriamo per non annoiarci;
corriamo perché abbiamo paura,
e ci nascondiamo dietro la corsa
per nascondere anche i nostri limiti;
corriamo perché siamo
dannatamente competitivi,
e se arriviamo secondi ci rode;
corriamo perché se gli altri corrono
abbiamo paura a nostra volta
di rimanere soli;
corriamo perché confondiamo l'urgenza
con la nostra impazienza,
e ci dimentichiamo
dell'importanza delle cose.
Poi corriamo perché ci hanno detto
che prima o poi dobbiamo morire,
quindi meglio farne un po' di cose
prima che la signora in nero arrivi.
E corriamo perché la corsa diventa
la nostra meravigliosa coperta di Linus.
C'è una frase molto bella,
che Linus dice a Charlie Brown:
"La mia coperta
è quel metro scarso di flanella
che mi separa dall'esaurimento nervoso".
Ma quali sono i rischi di una corsa folle?
Beh sicuramente ci sono quelli fisici:
malattie gastriche, cardiovascolari,
disturbi dell'alimentazione.
E poi ci sono quelli emotivi:
non siamo più in grado
di concentrarci sulle cose,
la soglia di attenzione
crolla miseramente,
il nostro focus svanisce.
C'è una ricerca molto importante
che dice che l'attenzione dell'uomo, oggi,
è inferiore a quella del pesce rosso,
il che fa molto onore al pesce rosso.
Confondiamo e non siamo più in grado
di stabilire cosa è giusto,
cosa è sbagliato,
cosa è bello e cosa è brutto,
cosa è importante e cosa non lo è.
Inevitabilmente, prendiamo
decisioni sbagliate.
E poi non siamo più in grado di sognare,
di emozionarci e anche di amare.
E perdiamo gli altri intorno a noi,
ma forse siamo noi
che li abbiamo lasciati da soli.
Abbiamo perso, anche,
la capacità di ridere;
però ricordiamoci che ridere
è un condensato di forze.
In un vecchio TED, ho sentito dire
che ridere è come correre, meditare
e fare sesso, contemporaneamente.
Ma allora, corriamo o scappiamo?
E un'altra domanda:
(Applausi)
è tutto proprio così brutto?
Non c'è niente di buono nella corsa?
Ci sono molte cose buone,
perché quando corriamo accumuliamo
una grande quantità di energia,
ci sentiamo più forti, siamo galvanizzati
e cresce la nostra autostima
e ci mettiamo via anche un po'
di quel senso di onnipotenza
che poi ci servirà magari in futuro.
Quando corriamo viviamo gli stessi attimi
che si vivono quando siamo felici,
e a me è sempre capitato così.
E poi c'è un ormone magico che si sviluppa
anche nei momenti di stress positivo,
che è l'ossitocina,
che è un ormone che serve
a tantissime cose,
e serve anche a contrastare
le malattie cardiovascolari,
ad aumentare la resilienza allo stress.
Per cui, la chimica
che sta dietro la corsa
può rivelare, insomma,
sorprese e cose meravigliose.
Lo stress positivo, quindi,
può essere potenziante,
se viene vissuto come un alleato
e non come un nemico;
e soprattutto, se non diventa cronico.
Ecco, il nostro problema
è che molto spesso
trasformiamo le cose in croniche.
E alla fine, la risposta giusta
tra cosa dobbiamo fare,
è: "Dipende!"
"Non c'è vento favorevole, per il marinaio
che non sa dove andare" disse Seneca.
Noi dobbiamo sapere dove andare
e perché vogliamo andare in un posto
piuttosto che in un altro,
e quali sono gli strumenti
di cui abbiamo bisogno
per raggiungere quel posto,
incluso il ritmo.
Il piede sul freno o sull'acceleratore
ce l'abbiamo noi, nelle nostre mani:
non la società, le aspettative
che gli altri hanno per noi,
oppure le nostre paure.
Perché nella vita, a volte,
bisogna correre per rilasciare energia
o per accumulare energia,
per recuperare un ritardo
o magari mettere via un po' di vantaggio,
per tendere una mano a qualcuno
o per chiedere aiuto.
Oggi cammino.
Cammino perché vedo diritta
la strada davanti a me;
e quando c'è un bel rettilineo,
o una profonda discesa,
mi diverto anche a correre.
Cammino perché mi sono fatta
un sacco di amici, camminando;
e cammino perché,
quando lo faccio in compagnia,
mi faccio anche due chiacchiere,
perché la voglia di fare
due cose, tre, quattro contemporaneamente
non mi è ancora passata.
Cammino perché durante il cammino
posso raccogliere tantissime informazioni,
metterle via;
e quando sarò arrivata
in fondo al mio viaggio,
avrò imparato così tanto.
Che poi, non c'è un solo viaggio:
camminando, ci sono infiniti viaggi.
Cammino perché mi riposo;
e quando poi dovrò fare la volata,
sarò più performante.
Cammino perché mi prendo cura
di me e degli altri.
E soprattutto, cammino perché così
qualcun altro può allenarsi a correre.
Sono nata in ritardo,
per questo ho sempre corso,
ma ho imparato moltissimo
ad amare la bellezza della lentezza.
(Applausi)